on est dans la rue qui est
perpendiculaire à la clôture lubrizol
donc
j'habite ici et l'entrepôt vous voyez
juste en face là bas avec le avec la
culture verte c'est l'un des entrepôts
de lubrizol la nuit où c'est arrivé du
coup on était couchés
il était à peu près 4 heures du matin
donc j'étais avec ma femme sur le lit
d'un coup j'ai entendu une grosse
explosion et là les gros nuages de fumée
avec les grosses flammes qui montaient
sur plusieurs dizaines de mètres
on les voyait juste au dessus de la
toiture des maisons en face ce soit
que ce soit les nuisances olfactives que
ce soit les problèmes de myrtilles et de
vertiges de migraine de temps en temps
la gorge qui pique vraiment quand les
odeurs sont sont fortes les particules
qui sont encore et qui bougeait avec le
déblaiement des débris nous casse à
gratter au niveau de la gorge c'était
c'était vraiment pas agréable à c'est la
safra une semaine à la fin à la fin de
la semaine ça fera un an et un an après
on est encore gêné ça commence à
vraiment être loin et insupportable à
court terme
- il ya l'histoire des vertiges de maux
de tête mais on sait pas à long terme ce
qui peut ce que ça peut déclencher on ne
sait pas dans 10 ans si on sera pas
victime de
de problèmes cardiaques de cancers
autres
ça ne peut plus se reproduire parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons réduit de 80%
l'inventaire de produits conditionnés
qui est présent sur notre site
donc par définition la même chose ne
pourrait pas se reproduire sur ce site
ensuite izel
[Musique]